a few days
after my husband paul was diagnosed with
stage four lung cancer we were lying in
our bed at home
and paul said it's gonna be okay
and i remember answering back yes
we just don't know what ok means yet
paul and i had met as first year medical
students at yale
he was smart and kind and super funny
he used to keep a gorilla suit in the
trunk of his car
and he'd say it's for emergencies only
i fell in love with paul as i watched
the care he took with his patients
he stayed late talking with them seeking
to understand
the experience of illness and not just
its technicalities
he later told me he fell in love with me
when he saw me cry
over an ekg of a heart that had ceased
beating
we didn't know it yet but even in the
heady days of young love
we were learning how to approach
suffering together
we got married and became doctors i was
working
as an internist and paul was finishing
his training as a neurosurgeon
when he started to lose weight
he developed excruciating back pain and
a cough
that wouldn't go away and when he was
admitted to the hospital
a ct scan revealed tumors in paul's
lungs and in his bones
we had both care for patients with
devastating diagnoses
now it was our turn
we lived with paul's illness for 22
months
he wrote a memoir about facing mortality
i gave birth to our daughter katie and
we loved her and each other
we learned directly how to struggle
through really tough medical decisions
the day we took paul into the hospital
for the last time
was the most difficult day of my life
when he turned to me at the end and said
i'm ready i knew that wasn't just
a brave decision it was the right one
paul didn't want a ventilator and cpr
in that moment the most important thing
to paul was to hold our baby daughter
nine hours later paul died
i've always thought of myself as a
caregiver most physicians do
and taking care of paul deepened what
that meant
watching him reshape his identity during
his illness
learning to witness and accept his pain
talking together through his choices
those experiences taught me that
resilience does not mean bouncing back
to where you were before
or pretending that the hard stuff isn't
hard
it is so hard
it's painful messy stuff
but it's the stuff and i learned that
when we approach it together
we get to decide what success looks like
one of the first things paul said to me
after his diagnosis was
i want you to get remarried
and i was like whoa i guess we get to
say anything out loud
it was so shocking and heartbreaking
and generous and really comforting
because it was so historically honest
and that honesty turned out to be
exactly what we needed
early in paul's illness we agreed we
would just keep
saying things out loud
tasks like making a will or
completing our advance directives tasks
that i had always avoided
were not as daunting as they once seemed
i realized that completing an advanced
directive is an act of love
like a wedding vow a pack to take care
of someone
codifying the promise that till death do
us part
i will be there if needed
i will speak for you i will
honor your wishes
that paperwork became a tangible part of
our love story
as physicians paul and i were in a good
position to understand
and even accept his diagnosis
we weren't angry about it luckily
because we'd seen so many patients
in devastating situations and we knew
that death is a part of life
but it's one thing to know that it was a
very different experience to
actually live with the sadness and
uncertainty of a serious illness
huge strides are being made against lung
cancer
but we knew that paul likely had months
to a few years
left to live during that time paul wrote
about his transition from doctor to
patient
he talked about feeling like he was
suddenly at a crossroads
and how he would have thought he'd be
able to see the path
that because he treated so many patients
maybe he could follow in their footsteps
but he was totally disoriented
rather than a path paul wrote
i saw instead only a harsh
vacant gleaming white desert
as if a sandstorm had erased all
familiarity
i had to face my mortality and try to
understand
what made my life worth living and i
needed my oncologist's help
to do so
the clinicians taking care of paul gave
me an even deeper appreciation for my
colleagues in healthcare
we have a tough job we're responsible
for helping patients have clarity
around their prognoses and their
treatment options
and that's never easy but it's
especially tough when you're dealing
with potentially
terminal illnesses like cancer
some people don't want to know how long
they have left
others do either way we never have those
answers
sometimes we substitute hope
by emphasizing the best case scenario
in a survey of physicians 55
said they painted a rosier picture than
their honest
opinion when describing a patient's
prognosis
it's an instinct born out of kindness
but researchers have found that when
people better understand
the possible outcomes of an illness they
have
less anxiety greater ability to plan
and less trauma for their families
families can struggle with those
conversations but for us we also
found that information immensely helpful
with big decisions most notably
whether to have a baby
months to a few years meant paul was not
likely to see her grow up
but he had a good chance of being there
for her birth and for the beginning of
her life
i remember asking paul if he thought
having to say goodbye to a child would
make dying even more painful
this answer astounded me he said
wouldn't it be great if it did
and we did it not in order to spite
cancer but because we were learning
that living fully means
suffering
paul's oncologist tailored his chemo so
he could continue
working as a neurosurgeon which
initially we thought was totally
impossible
when the cancer advanced and paul
shifted from surgery to writing
his palliative care doctor prescribed a
stimulant medication
so he could be more focused they
asked paul about his priorities and his
worries
they asked him what trade-offs he was
willing to make
those conversations are the best way
to ensure that your healthcare matches
your values paul joked that it's not
like that birds and bees talk you have
with your parents where you all get it
over with as quickly as possible and
then pretend it never happened
you revisit the conversation as things
change
you keep saying things out loud
i'm forever grateful because paul's
clinicians felt
that their job wasn't to try to give us
answers they didn't have or
only to try to fix things for us but to
counsel paul
through painful choices when his body
was failing but his will to live
wasn't later after paul died i received
a dozen bouquets of flowers but i sent
just one
to paul's oncologist because
she supported his goals and she helped
him
weigh his choices she knew
that living means more than just staying
alive
a few weeks ago a patient came into my
clinic a woman
dealing with a serious chronic disease
and while we were talking about her life
and her health care she said
i love my palliative care team
they taught me that it's okay to say no
yeah i thought of course it is
but many patients don't feel that
compassion and choices did a study where
they asked people
about their health care preferences and
a lot of people started their answers
with the words well if i had a choice
if i had a choice and when i read that
if i understood better
why one in four people receives
excessive or unwanted medical treatment
or watches a family member receive
excessive
or unwanted medical treatment
it's not because doctors don't get it we
do
we understand the real psychological
consequences
on patients and their families
the thing is we deal with them too
half of critical care nurses and a
quarter of icu doctors
have considered quitting their jobs
because of distress
over feeling that for some of their
patients they've provided care
that didn't fit with the person's values
but doctors can't make sure your wishes
are respected until they know
what they are would you want to be on
life support if it offered any chance of
longer life
are you most worried about the quality
of that time
rather than quantity both of those
choices
are thoughtful and brave but for all of
us it's our choice
that's true at the end of life and for
medical care throughout our lives
if you're pregnant do you want genetic
screening is a knee replacement right or
not
do you want to do dialysis in a clinic
or at home
the answer is it depends
what medical care will help you live
the way you want to
i hope you remember that question the
next time you face a decision in your
health care
remember that you always have a choice
and it is okay to say no
to a treatment that's not right for you
there's a poem by w.s merwin
it's just two sentences long the capture
is how i feel now
your absence has gone through me
like thread through a needle
everything i do is stitched with its
color
for me that poem evokes my love for paul
and a new fortitude that came from
loving
and losing him when paul
said it's going to be okay that didn't
mean
that we could cure his illness instead
we learned to accept both joy and
sadness at the same time
to uncover beauty and purpose
both despite and because
we are all born and we all die
and for all the sadness and sleepless
nights
it turns out there is joy i leave
flowers on paul's grave
and watch our two-year-old run around on
the grass
i build bonfires on the beach and watch
the sunset
with our friends exercise and
mindfulness meditation
have helped a lot and someday
i hope i do get remarried
most importantly i get to watch our
daughter grow
i've thought a lot about what i'm going
to say
to her when she's older
katie engaging in the full range of
experience
living and dying love and loss
is what we get to do
being human doesn't happen
despite suffering
it happens within it
when we approach suffering together when
we choose not to hide from it
our lives don't diminish they expand
i've learned that cancer isn't always a
battle
or if it is maybe it's a fight for
something different than we thought
our job isn't to fight fate
but to help each other through
not as soldiers but as
shepherds
that's how we make it okay even when
it's not
by saying it out loud by helping
each other through
and a gorilla suit never hurts either
thank you
you